je me trouve en ille-et-vilaine had
rouge un petit village d'un peu plus de
500 habitants je viens rencontrer sa
mère patricia marc se lier et se bat
quotidiennement pour maintenir
l'attractivité de cette commune rurale
elle va nous raconter suivez moi madame
la maire bonjour merci de nous recevoir
je vais vous laisser vous présentez vous
êtes maire de cette commune depuis
combien de temps je suis maire depuis
cinq ans bientôt et lieu depuis 1998
expliqué mme anticipé le quotidien d'une
mer dans une petite commune comme celle
ci le quotidien ça à 20,2
de la gestion d'une voix qui est cabinet
à un particulier qu'est les soucis à des
démarches administratif a validé en ce
moment c'est
la préparation des budgets actuellement
et puis là on accueille les dépôts de
candidatures pour notre d'un resto on va
aller voir un petit peu devant racontez
moi vous l'avez il a fermé à combien de
temps cet établissement juste deux ans
juste avant le confinement de dénis 20
vous avez eu déjà des dépôts de
candidature pour une reprise de la faire
d'ici fin février j'espère pouvoir avoir
une suite favorable à donner à quelqu'un
je suppose que c'était un des lieux
principaux d'activité du village c'est
la place principale du village vous avez
senti une différence après dans
l'ambiance après du village puisqu'il
avait plus lieu de rendez vous havas est
clair une façade de commerces fermés il
ya moins de monde à venir relever
d'autres des commerces ici c'est notre
dernier commerce vont nous fait visiter
la commune allez on y va c'est parti
d'une
donc là si jamais je viens m'installer à
drouges je peux être autosuffisant six
mois de l'année c'est ça oui exactement
si vous aimez bien le poisson problème
d'accord vous aimez le poisson blague à
part c'est quoi le budget d'une d'une
commune comme comme rouge votre budget à
vous c'est quoi ici mais on va
s'installer en général on est à 200
mille euros et voir un petit que moi et
en fonctionnement on est entre 150 et
200 euros qu'est ce que ça dit dudu du
rôle de l'état
dans le développement de ces de ces
zones-là de communes comme la vo de ces
zones rurales écoutez moi je pense qu à
plus ou moins court terme les petites
communes comme la nôtre
n'existeront plus on parle souvent de la
france rurale comme étant la france
oubliez c'est quelque chose que dans
laquelle vous vous reconnaissez vous
êtes une à france oubliée ou pas je peux
vous assurer que oui à quel niveau
déjà frapper aux bonnes portes c'est
très compliqué
avoir des réponses c'est très compliqué
et se sentir soutenu c'est très
compliqué on a perdu tous nos
administrations du trésor public
les administrations pour les actes
administrative ne serait ce que pour les
instructions permis de construire qui
sont maintenant sur vitry a manqué alors
qu'ils étaient à la guerche avant qu'on
a perdu toutes les
c'est un
service de proximité qui aujourd'hui
font que le l'administré n'a plus de
contacts avec les les gens
avec qui ils sont censés discuté il ya
plus de discussions sur le consacre à
100% pour la commune j'ai lâché une
activité professionnelle
donc chaque jour je me dis bah écoute
la personne qui va venir aujourd'hui te
voir tu l'accueil tulle écoute tu résout
le problème qui est la résoudre
j'ai pas forcément difficulté à ce
niveau là quoi mais
c'est prenant c'est très prenant propose
qu'on reste là on est bien face à des
temps pour aborder un petit peu le sujet
de la présidentielle c'est toujours bien
d'avoir un cadre un petit peu serein
pour aborder ce genre de question qu'est
ce que devrait vous dire un candidat à
la présidentielle on a plein de
candidats à la présidentielle en ce
moment qu'est ce qui devrait vous dire
pour vous convaincre de voter pour lui
en tant que maire et ben pourquoi pas
rembourser aux gens qui se déplacent en
voiture une partie de leurs frais de
carburant comme il est fait pour les
gens qui utilisent leur vélo parce que
ça c'est fait pour les gens qui
utilisent leur vélo mais
la france rurale a pas le choix pour la
voiture voilà c'est ça et donc
l'autonomie il n'a pas du tout n'est pas
du tout concerné et je trouve que ce
serait une bonne initiative ça passe
vraiment si loin que ça ah je pense que
ça pèse de plus en plus ah bah oui